tétraplégique
ils consomment du cannabis pour soulager
des douleurs importantes sous forme de
joint ou avec une vaporeuse
il prend jusqu'à 6 grammes de cannabis à
chaque jour son propriétaire actuel
tolère la situation mais jonathan a dû
quitter deux autres immeubles à
logements dont une coopérative en raison
de sa consommation
mais là ma maison mais ce n'était pas
assez pour les couche-tard partie jetant
devant rien et est toujours question
voda parce que sa santé est fragile il a
à chaque fois quitté sans contester
devant la régie du logement
mais même certains locataires qui se
défendent pour conserver le droit de
fumer du cannabis médicinal perdre leur
cause
c'est le cas d'un locataire de matane
qui sera expulsé dans la foulée d'un
jugement de la régie du logement
on peut y lire que le locataire par
l'inhalation de la fumée de marijuana de
façon récurrente dans son logement est
une source d'ennuis et porte atteinte
aux droits des autres occupants de
l'immeuble
c'est très inquiétant parce qu' on parle
de locataires donc qui ont besoin de
consommer du cannabis pour leur
bien-être
surtout que dans ce cas si le cannabis
consommé est légal donc on a deux droit
qui s'opposent mais on peut pas
privilégier une personne au détriment
d'une majorité depuis 2015 la régie du
logement a entendu des dizaines de
causes portant sur la consommation de
cannabis
le genre de conflits qui pourraient se
multiplier
lorsque le cannabis sera totalement
légaliser plus tard cette année
il va y avoir un problème de gestion d'
imam c'est sûr on le voit déjà de
produits ti légal à partir du moment où
il devient légal plus de ge avons
consommé du cannabis plus de gens
évoqueront leur droit de fumer chez eux
consommé du cannabis même une fois
légaliser pourrait devenir assez
compliqué c'est lee viennent
il n'y avait pas les gens fumer dans une
table en or puis que les gens peuvent
pas fumer chez eux où ils vont pouvoir
consommer un produit qui est légal qui
est vendu ce tribut et les propriétaires
pourront effectivement interdire la
consommation de cannabis dans les
logements
lors du renouvellement des baux de
location ici david gêne-t-il radio
canada montréal